through the gates of balmoral it was the
quietest farewell
rural aberdeenshire its birth song and
the rumble of the river d
leave the soundtrack for a sight most
sadly
the hairs carried the queen's coffin
wrapped in the royal standard of
scotland
the wreath on top was made from her
favorite flowers picked from the
balmoral guard
in the car behind the queen was escorted
by her daughter the princess royal and
her husband sir tim lawrence
the geography of circumstance had placed
the queen in balmoral when she passed
at journey's end there will be a state
funeral set peace ceremony and all that
but between here and there this was an
informal farewell an opportunity for the
public to save their goodbyes
in balloter near balmoral they lined the
streets
here they knew her as the queen next
door their village was her village
it's just so fond of this area
it's just a very sad day for us all
very emotional today and very proud
to be part of the united kingdom so yeah
i cried
everybody here you see them all crying i
just found it really emotional
it's like it's almost like saying
goodbye to a family member it's just
really really upsetting
tractors were positioned by the side of
the road an agricultural guard of honour
as the cortege wound a route through
rural scotland
horse riders too
formed up in a field by the roadside as
it made its slow six hour journey south
this journey had been meticulously
planned
even if there was no public rehearsal
here in banquet there was applause
[Applause]
elsewhere there was silence
everywhere there was respect and
remembrance
it was it was quite overwhelming to be
honest i'm very very proud to be here
i've never come along to anything like
this before but just really felt that i
wanted it was it was important
it was beautiful
once in a lifetime it's not gonna happen
again
people line dual carriageways linking
aberdeen dundee and edinburgh beyond and
they looked on from walkways overhead
closer to edinburgh the cortege crossed
the fourth of fourth via the queensferry
crossing a bridge officially opened by
the queen in
2017 members of the royal family had
traveled ahead by helicopter to fulfill
their duties
once in edinburgh the queen's coffin was
driven through the streets towards
hollywood in the city's old town
[Applause]
the royal regiment of scotland formed a
guard of honour at the palace of
hollywood house and the queen's coffin
was received with a royal salute
it's being placed in the throne room
overnight to allow palace staff to pay
their respects
as the queen was carried inside a
daughter court said to her mother
her duty done
this was day one of the queen's long
goodbye
which will span a nation that grew with
her and having learned of her loss is
learning to live with it
james matthews sky news in ballet